what's the worst thing that's going to
happen if you start believing that
you're the hottest alive here's what i
don't like about that statement why do
you want to say hottest instead of just
hot
it's a superlative that implies
competition is it because you're still
basing your self-worth on how you
compete with other
hot aka woman just
stop using super hot days this is the
stupidest
thing that i've seen in at least the
past 12 seconds yes it turns out that
life is filled with competition it is
well known by virtually every social
science study that there is competition
for mates
it's true in evolutionary biology and so
that competition does exist and you can
either pretend it doesn't exist or you
can recognize that it does exist but uh
this person seems very very angry about
superlatives which makes them the
craziest person that i've seen in the
last few seconds at least because i'm
watching these videos back to back and
frankly i just want to
run directly like screaming through a
playglass window
[Music]